[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue au parlement
européen ravi de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle année une année qui
s'annonce riche en actualité européenne
dans la seconde partie de cette émission
focus sur l'obligation vaccinale entrée
en vigueur en france début janvier ces
onze vaccins obligatoires n'en finissent
plus de faire polémique
contrairement à l'allemagne ou sans
obligation la couverture vaccinale est
plus importante
reportages et débats tout à l'heure mais
d'abord l'actualité
l'allemagne encore et toujours va-t-elle
enfin sortir de l'impasse politique
après des semaines de blocage un pré
accord électoral a été négocié entre
conservateurs et sociaux démocrates
retour sur les faits avec amelia morgat
dit
après plus de 100 jours sans
gouvernement l'allemagne pourrait enfin
sortir du flou un préaccord a été publié
le 12 janvier entre les conservateurs de
la cdu août ces asu menée par angela
merkel et les sociaux démocrates du spd
conduits par martin schulz le leader
socialiste revient donc sur l'engagement
pris par son parti de ne plus participer
à une grande coalition afin d'éviter la
tenue de nouvelles élections et un
blocage politique à long terme
l'accord tente un équilibre délicat
le premier chapitre est consacré aux
avancées de la politique européenne
concessions faites à martin schulz de
leur côté les conservateurs imposent
leur position en matière de politique
migratoire
l'allemagne ne pourra pas accueillir
plus de 200 mille demandeurs d'asile
chaque année un bricolage qui n'est pas
du goût de tous cet accord est une farce
pour le parti d'extrême droite
afp les verts soulignent l'inhumanité de
certaines mesures migratoire tandis que
la gauche die linke tire la sonnette
d'alarmé sur les questions sociales
emmanuel macron a quant à lui salué un
accord plus favorable au projet européen
ce pré accord devra être validé le 21
janvier prochain lors du congrès
extraordinaire du spd il devrait servir
de base aux négociations d'un futur
gouvernement de grande coalition
[Musique]
et pour en débattre j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir mes invités michèle rivasi
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne de
vous êtes membre du groupe des verts ici
au parlement en face de vous françoise
grossetête vous êtes également députée
française ici au parlement et vous êtes
vice présidente du groupe parti
populaire européen donc membre des
républicains en france et enfin iacob
von weizsacker vous êtes amant et vous
êtes membre du groupe socialiste et
démocrate bienvenus ma première question
s'adresse à vous il ya koba ce que vous
considérez que c'est une volte-face à
renoncement de la part des socialistes
ce pré accord de coalition la situation
pour pour nous les sociaux-démocrates en
allemagne c'est difficile tout d'abord
on a eu vraiment un grand échec dans les
élections législatives et donc la
réaction immédiate c'est à dire voilà si
on perdre l'élection il faut aller dans
l'opposition bien sûr et après revenir
en force mais malheureusement la
coalition alternative n'a pas réussi à
trouver une solution entre eux donc
selon vous c'est quoi c'est le sens de
responsabilité des socialistes qui m'a
fait la seule possibilité de former un
gouvernement sable sont des nouvelles
élections c'est la grande coalition
et ça c'est la question clé à la fin
question est-ce qu'une coalition qui a
déjà gouverné l'allemagne pendant
longtemps
est ce qu'elle peut vraiment former un
bon projet pour l'avenir de la manif est
là et c'est pas un hasard que dans
l'après traité de coalition
c'est l'europe qui est au centre est une
manière de le voir c'est si on va
réussir de vraiment avec la france avec
mc ren relancer le projet européen
résoudre le problème de schengen le
problème qu'on n'a pas une bonne gestion
des problèmes de réfugiés en europe
résoudre le problème de l'euro qui
causent des maisons à vendre à vos
à votre belle si on pourrait réussir ça
on pourrait espérer d'avoir un grand
coalition qui renforce ce centre est de
toute façon la décision n'a pour
l'instant 21 janvier en incombe à la
base de vos militants
françoise grossetête il est urgent que
l'allemagne sorte de ce blocage
politique parce qu'en l'état aujourd'hui
on n'a personne avec qui discuter en
france est globalement au niveau
européen pour faire avancer l'union
il est évident qu'on a absolument besoin
d'une allemagne avec un gouvernement
stable et avec lequel on pourra
effectivement mené les négociations pour
aller de l'avant
je suis complètement d'accord avec ce
que vous avez dit il faut régler un
certain nombre de problèmes qui sont des
problèmes très importants et très
sensible pour nos concitoyens les
frontières le contrôle des frontières
le problème migratoire problèmes de la
zone euro ce sont des questions
fondamentales si on arrive ensemble à
faire des propositions crédibles pour
l'union européenne et à résoudre ces
questions là mais le temps est court
d'ici les élections européennes
contrôler 2019 bien à ce moment là on
aura convaincu que nous nos concitoyens
qu'il ne faut pas être tourné en voilà
des déviations extrémistes
eurosceptiques
mais les enjeux sont très forts et nous
avons vraiment intérêt à travailler
ensemble
ça c'est fondamental mais initial rivasi
quand vous voyez le retour de merkel
tout du moins donc pour possible
quatrième mandat martin schulz qui
pourtant a été défait on a un peu
l'impression en fait d'un espèce
d'anciens monde qui cherche à tout prix
à se maintenir
est ce que ce n'est pas une mauvaise
image aussi en terme de renouvellement
alors que les allemands ont clairement
lors des législatives en fait balayer un
petit peu ce monde ancien entre guy
c'est vrai que c'est surprenant que l'on
pose pas le problème de ces 4e mandat
merkel et moi ça me donne l'impression
que l'allemagne a peur du changement
quand il ya eu la coalition jamaïque
voyez avec les libéraux et avec les
vaines tentatives way avec art
des propositions nouvelles et ses
libéraux très eurosceptique et qu'on
fait capoter l'accord mais quand j'ai
regardé mois la feuille de route mois la
feuille de route elle est très décevante
que ce soit sur le climat enfin quand on
regarde la feuille de route sur le
climat ils vont même pas respecter les
accords de 2020 et encore moins ceux de
quand on regarde et sur la migration les
propositions qui sont faites
elles sont à minima par rapport au
discours de solidarité qui est tenu et
sur l'europe et c'est ça qui me surprend
dans votre discours vous avez
l'impression de dire qu'il faut résoudre
les problèmes européens par rapport à
une politique allemande mais il n'ya
rien d'innovant et si on veut vraiment
refaire aimer l'europe il faut a annoncé
une europe innovante une europe plus
solidaire et dans le programme de la
coalition que j'ai entendu et ben c'est
ventre mou françois gross est vous êtes
d'accord
madame merkel a quand même même si elle
a eu un score moins brillant que les
précédentes sélections est là elle a
gagné elle a gagné
alors on sait qu'en en allemagne il faut
des coalitions la coalition alternative
qui avait été initialement ce avec les
libéraux et les verts avec les libéraux
et les verts n'a pas n'a pas fonctionné
ça me paraissait quand même être
l'obligation elle n'avait jamais existé
entre les positions des verts et les
positions du libéro moi je me demandais
comment ça pouvait fonctionner sans que
les libéraux pour être clair sont plutôt
sceptiques un wii sont eurosceptiques
tout à fait ça c'est la difficulté
c'était la difficulté bon donc
moi je pense que cette coalition elle et
elle est nécessaire si c'est saluée par
paris
c'est parce que de toute façon faut
sortir d'une impasse on a besoin d'une
allemagne avec un gouvernement stable
même si cela ne satisfait pas tout le
monde
il faut sortir de cette impasse et le
plus rapidement possible il ya comme un
joker est ce que à l'image de ce que dit
michèle rivasi
cet accord selon vous est réchauffé et
ce qu'il faudrait pas aussi penser à la
suite c'est à dire l'après merkel bien
sûr il faut le penser c'est que c'est
clair il n'y aura pas après quatre
années et si on arrive à former une
coalition
encore une fois un mandat pour merkel ça
c'est clair
et la grande question c'est est ce qu'on
va arriver à vraiment aux où le problème
européen
là je suis pas tout à fait d'accord si
on compare le le contrat qui était déjà
négocié entre les collectionneurs
jamaïque et inclut les verts sur
l'europe
ici on regarde le précontrat en a
maintenant dans une possible grand
coalition ce pré contrat est beaucoup
plus pro européen et là je vois la
possibilité c'est pas une garantie
mais c'est la possibilité d'un vrai
relance pour l'europe avec mc ren en
utilisant le temps et le temps est court
vous avez marqué sur son ancien
président du parlement européen à 19
ils ont présenté quelque chose donc il
faut maintenant se dépêcher mais faut
vraiment avoir la volonté sur la
dimension intérieure je suis d'accord il
ya beaucoup de points pour nous que la
social-démocratie est très difficile
oui mais sur l'europe je suis pas du
tout d'accord sur l'europe ait une vraie
opportunité là dedans il faut il faut le
voir mais mais du reste de toute façon
tout ceci sera conditionnée à la
validation donc par les militants et
pour l'instant rien n'est fait on est
d'accord bonne forme de 21 donc on reste
en allemagne
mais depuis le 1er janvier vous le savez
11 vaccins sont devenus obligatoires en
france l'annoncé par la ministre de la
santé
agnès buzyn il ya quelques mois de
l'élargissement de cette obligation
vaccinale initialement donc prévue à 3 a
bien entendu suscité une
norm polémique qui a fait bondir bon
nombre de parents de citoyens nous avons
été voir à berlin où pour le coup en
allemagne donc cette obligation
vaccinale n'existe pas et pourtant le
taux de couverture vaccinale
il est bien plus important reportage de
cendres à certains
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à des
effets secondaires
il peut y avoir des complications des
mamans inquiètes ce pédiatre en
rencontrent fréquemment dans son cabinet
car en allemagne aussi les vaccins font
débat 21% des allemands sont convaincus
que les vaccins provoquent des allergies
70% pensent même qu'il est bon de
contracter des maladies pour renforcer
les défenses immunitaires des enfants
karina aussi avaient des doutes faire
vacciner son enfant n'allait pas de soi
on en parle beaucoup avec mes amis et
autour de moi tous les parents ne
vaccinent pas leurs enfants
c'est un sujet très controversé le corps
médical doit faire face et apprendre à
mieux communiquer sur les vaccins
diphtérie tétanos poliomyélite ont jol
coqueluche au total neuf souches sont
proposés dans le programme national de
vaccination font du scepticisme à
l'égard des vaccins c'est indéniable il
y en a il ya beaucoup plus de
questionnements depuis quelques années
des parents sceptiques
on doit les convaincre beaucoup discuter
du bien fondé de la vaccination mais
comme notre taux de vaccination reste
élevé proche des 95%
cela veut dire que nous y arrivons
depuis de récentes épidémies de rougeole
une maladie qui peut être mortelle
l'allemagne durci sa législation en 2015
et rend obligatoire
cette consultation pédiatrique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 2017 la loi est encore renforcée et
oblige crèches et écoles à signaler les
parents qui refusent de voir un médecin
pour parler vaccination risque en 2500
euros damende tout va bien dans cette
crèche de l'est de berlin
parmi les 54 enfants accueillis 10 ne
sont pas vaccinés
pour la directrice rien de choquant elle
estime que faire vacciner son enfant ou
nous relève de la liberté individuelle
[Musique]
nous demandons aux parents de remplir
une attestation qui détaille quelle
maladie l'enfant a déjà eu ce qui nous
permet de savoir si l'état de santé de
l'enfant est compatible avec l'accueil
en collectivité le pédiatre doit signer
le document pour attester que la
consultation a bien eu lieu
seule la preuve de cette consultation
est exigée pas les vaccins
par les vaccinations avec un médecin
sans pour autant faire vacciner son
enfant
certains y verraient une forme de
laxisme au contraire affirment ce
directeur de recherches en allemagne où
la vaccination est recommandée
seules 10,5 pour cent de la population
s'oppose aux vaccins contre 41% des
français pour qui c'est obligatoire les
études montrent qu'en allemagne
l'obligation vaccinale créerait à coup
sûr de la résistance dans la population
et serait contre-productive
c'est bien plus efficace de
responsabiliser les parents
la vaccination est une bonne chose la
rendre contraignante crée du doute et ne
permet pas de voir les vaccins comme
quelque chose d'utile dans l'intérêt
général et pour la santé en 2010 est
plus de 900 cas de rougeole ont été
déclarés trois fois plus qu'en 2016 une
preuve pour sept parlementaires que la
législation allemande ne va pas assez
loin malgré tout le travail de pédagogie
mise en place certains parents restent
réfractaires et n'arrive pas à se
représenter la dangerosité des maladies
ce sont des maladies qui n'ont pas
disparu et qui mettent en danger des
enfants qui ne peuvent pas décider par
eux-mêmes de se protéger ou non son
inquiétude
l'activisme des anti vaccins et la
crainte qu'à terme les taux de
vaccination ne baisse en allemagne y
compris chez les adultes danse est
achetable hostage romance tout sauf mon
snow leopard dans la ville d'où je viens
düsseldorf
on a dû fermer des écoles entières à
cause d'épidémie de rougeole les enfants
contamine les parents qui eux mêmes sont
mal vaccinés
il faut mettre en place l'obligation
vaccinale car les conséquences peuvent
être vraiment très grave
à l'heure où l'europe est coupée en deux
entre pays ou vacciner est obligatoire
et d'autres seulement recommandée bon
nombre d'industriels veulent harmoniser
au niveau européen la composition des
injections et des calendriers vaccinaux
les mêmes règles pour tous pour tenter
d'en finir avec les polémiques
il ya comme balzac heures qu'est ce que
vous qu'est ce que vous avez à dire de
la manière dont la france en fait à
gérer cette question de l'obligation
vaccinale ans on voit encore
potentiellement en allemagne sans
obligation la couverture est meilleur
comment est ce que vous voyez ce débat
français pour moi l'essentiel c'est de
d'avant toute vaccination extrêmement
élevés pour des raisons individuelles
parce que ça protège chacun qui est
vacciné mais aussi pour les problèmes
que raison collectif parce que
évidemment si un taux de vaccination
très élevé la poèmes esprit grenier 95
d'une épidémie est beaucoup plus bas je
pense on peut apprendre entre les pays
européens entre entre nous et voir quel
est le bon approche est peut-être savary
même entre les pays européens jouent il
ya peut-être la culture las écologie là
que tu veux et tu es qu' il ne faut pas
une harmonisation absolue donc moi je
suis extrêmement pragmatique là-dessus
mais je ne suis pas pragmatique sur le
but
oui le plomb et doit être averti en
vaccinale la citation est important de
préciser françois de grosses têtes quand
on voit le modèle allemand nous ferons
nous parle souvent du modèle allemand
est ce que là dessus quand on voit la
pédagogique et mises en oeuvre
est-ce que c'est pas une meilleure
solution qu'une obligation quand on voit
que quatre français sur dix en fait
rejette aujourd'hui la vaccination ou
alors je suis d'abord très inquiète de
ce positionnement des français je pense
que là il ya quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas que l'auto manche il me
tète un manque de pédagogie avec ce que
mon collègue vient de dire c'est une
responsabilité non seulement
individuelle et collective cette
responsabilité je rappelle quand même
pour une maladie comme la rougeole qui
tue considéré comme une maladie
infantile entre 2000
2008 et 2012 à peu près il ya eu 23 1000
cas de rougeole il y a eu dix décès mais
ce sont dix décès de trop pour une
maladie qui peut être totalement
évitez-vous qui en italie et l'allemand
eon roumaine présente pour des enfants
la disparition d'enfants qui ne devrait
devrait pas avoir lieu alors que ces
maladies sont potentiellement
l'éradiquer mais exactement
donc je rappelle les pays aurait
beaucoup d'autres exemples qu'on
pourrait donner donc les changes des
bonnes pratiques est certainement
quelque chose de d'efficace néanmoins il
y à des cultures différentes
les français sont toujours des frondeurs
et il suffit qu'on leur impose quelque
chose pour qu'ils aient tous les doutes
sur ce qu'on va leur imposer
et ça c'est regrettable quand il s'agit
de vaccination parce que c'est quand
même ça concerne la santé la santé de
leurs enfants
mais la santé de la population donc
ccravh dans ce cas là mais il n'y a pas
eu des errements aussi michèle rivasi de
la part des différents ministères de la
santé de la part des différentes
structures en fait chargé tout ça on a
l'impression d'un silence coupable
autour de ces questions de vaccination
il n'y a pas de débat et d'un seul coup
au 1er janvier 11 vaccin obligatoire ça
ne peut dans l'esprit frondeur francs
seraient potentiellement que suscité de
la défiance mais je trouve que le
véritable problème c'est la confiance
vont et viendra au fiancé rompu et la
confiance est rompue et à lesparrou pu
alors c'est vrai que ça moi même de
culture je vous expliquer pourquoi il ya
eu le scandale de la grippe h1n1 ou la
ministre madame bachelot à l'époque
avait acheté 90 millions de doses sur
une grippette qui avaient été reconnus
par des professeurs de l'affronter
donc les gens se sont dit pourquoi avoir
acheté autant de vaccins sur une grippe
cas pas été plus pénalisante que les
autres et que d'autres pays justement
mais pas choisi d'acheter des vaccins
donc ça a été le premier script il ya eu
d'autres scandales sur l'hépatite b ou à
une époque c'était sous monsieur douste
blazy
on a voulu dire à tous les ados il faut
vous vacciner une médiation obligatoire
à l'école dans les années 90 alors
c'était pas vraiment obligatoire mais
s'était fortement ortement conseiller et
puis il ya eu des cas de sclérose en
plaques et en a arrêté le fait de
vacciner en disant il
mieux vacciner peut-être des nourrissons
que les ados parce que ça peut entraîner
des problèmes
donc voyez il ya cette défiance et puis
il ya plein de conflits d'intérêts chez
nous le responsable du centre de
techniques de vaccination qui élaboré le
calendrier vaccinal était quelqu'un qui
était financée par les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et d'ailleurs dans le
reportage
il a été dit les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques demande une
harmonisation sur le plan européen
mais de quel droit ces les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques qui vont décider voyez
de la vaccination
alors là où je vous suis c'est pas le
problème de la vaccination il faut que
les gens se fassent vacciner c'est le
problème de l'obligation et ses sacs qui
pêchent en attendant de retrouver cette
confiance de recréer le lien de
confiance parce qu'on sent bien qu'il ya
un problème de pédagogie autour de ces
questions est ce qu'on peut s'apprendre
le risque de jeunes gens qui sont
touchés par la coqueluche par la
tuberculose par la rubéole et de et de
perdre en fait des nourrissons il faut
peut-être aussi en passer une obligation
autant les amis d'amy il n'y a pas
d'épidémie de coqueluche n'y a pas
d'épidémie de rumeurs il ya
effectivement des cas de rougeole et ben
ce moment là disons aux gens on a
observé des cas de rougeole important il
faut vous faire vacciner et les jo si
vous faites ça au cas par cas
ils sont capables de suivre regardez
quand il ya eu ce qu'assure là quand
même c'est vachement important ça
la vaccination contre la dengue sanofi
sort vaccin y vaccine 700000 gamin aux
philippines qu'est ce qui s'est passé on
s'aperçoit que les gamins qui sont
vaccinées provoquant cas de dengue des
effets beaucoup plus importants que les
gamins qui sont pas vaccinés comment se
fait-il qu'ils aient pas eu plus
d'études cliniques qui voulaient les
gens moi je suis pour une vaccination ou
au cas par cas
on regarde si le vaccin il est vraiment
indispensable françois 07 l'obligation
sur ans vaccin est ce que dans les pays
où il existe une obligation vaccinale
les résultats sont meilleurs en termes
de couverture vaccinale n'ont alors pas
n'est pas nécessairement
c'est regrettable je pense qu'il ya de
la pédagogie à faire
mais et surtout se baser quand même sur
des avis scientifiques sur or
malheureusement en france on a donné
beaucoup plus la parole à quelques rares
soit disant scientifiques qui se
permettait d'avoir des positionnements
extrêmement grave grave parce qu'ils
peuvent influencer des personnes qui
effectivement peut-être pas accès à une
information suffisamment complète pour
ne pas faire vacciner leurs enfants et
je trouve cela très grave
évitons les épidémies et vaccinaux la
prévention c'est toujours préférable oui
oui mais là sur des vaccins et après des
cas où il n'y a pas eu de sécurité des
vaccins il ya toute une polémique sur
les adjuvants sur les vaccins
l'aluminium vous répondre alors cela oui
justement parce qu'on vit est peut-être
études là dessus l'aluminium sont faits
pour être clair pour le téléspectateur
sur la question de l'aider à du vent
c'est qu'il ya de l'aluminium dans les
vaccins alors on retient les sels
d'aluminium des déodorants mais pas des
vaccins dont il ya beaucoup de journaux
me disent que ya potentiellement aussi
là dessus une problématique à régler oui
non mais alors attendez sur les
adjuvants et entre autres aluminium
je crois que ça suffit il faut pas en
faire toute une histoire
l'aluminium présents dans les vaccins
c'est 0,6 mg faut que vous sachiez que
quotidiennement nous sommes nous nous
absorbons par différents moyens d
quantité d'aluminium entre 3 mg et 15 mg
faut savoir dans une plaquette de
chocolat
il y a ah oui et béthune gère la tunique
non mais faut alerter avec cela c'est
pas la même chose il faut parer l'engin
ne pas arrêter avec cela je crois que le
dosage d'aluminium comme a dû vendre le
x1 est tellement infimes que ça n'a pas
d'incidence selon résidence et c'est
démontrer alors faut arrêter avec ce
genre de même nom mais alors vous
voudrez l'agent cela serait connue
sécurité des médicaments recogné que
l'aluminium peut avoir un effet
neurotoxiques que ça passe pour les
doublants que samir dzebo faire tout à
fait donc même l' oms dia pas assez
d'études sur les autres du vent moi je
dis s'il ya une problème
par rapport à ces sept joueuses ont des
dernières questions peut-être jakobson
face à vous considérer qu'il ya une part
de théorie un peu du complot autour de
ça comment est ce que vous le percevez
voyez il ya deux problèmes c'est une
problème dans nos sociétés modernes un
peu plus général l'écart qu'il ya entre
l' expertise mondiale dans certains
domaines très élevé et la question quand
même comme citoyen normal non experts
comment est ce que je peux comprendre et
faire confiance d'où la colère de nos
savoirs dans le monde et il ya aussi des
parents qui s'intéressent pas trop
pandraud toutes ces théories mais ils
s'intéressent pas trop a même présenté
leurs enfants aux médecins et donc avoir
des mécanismes si c'est nécessaire
d'avoir une obligation de faire vacciner
les enfants ou une obligation par
exemple d'aller voir mettre ça au moins
une trouvaille on va discuter la
question ça c'est une manière de
protéger les enfants contre la
possibilité que leurs parents tout
simplement ceux s'intéressant
s'intéressent pas bon mois comme
social-démocrate d'avoir une mécanique
doit y avoir effectivement le rôle de
l'état et les enfants du maroc qui
s'intéressent pas trop à toutes ces
questions
pour moi c'est très important dans les
baies réformant les négliger donc
effectivement le rôle de l'état ici doit
être réaffirmée faire de la pédagogie
oui et faire en sorte que les épidémies
de conflit d'intérêts et ouais ça je
vous assure pour la question notamment
de très sympa le lobby d'ailleurs
massivement d'une compétence des états
membres mais je pense que l'europe aussi
a un rôle à jouer jouer au niveau de
recommandation à faire même peut-être
d'une information qui qui serait une
information européenne mais qui doit
être en phase ans s'est vu effectivement
la question des conflits d'intérêts
commerce aux parents ce sommet le 5 et
sio nerfs là dessus des voiliers pour
aller dans vu dans le cas de la
coopération renforcée sur la validation
qui est ouvert à tout public
donc je trouve que c'est bien que
l'europe l'europe on tarde de cette
question merci en tout cas pour tout de
suite c'est l'heure du tchèque
il ya quelques semaines les états unis
décidaient de revenir sur la sacro
sainte neutralité du net
la fin d'un totem qui fit chavirer
beaucoup de militants qui dès lors se
sont tournés vers l'union européenne
qu'est ce qu'il en est de la neutralité
du net en europe c'est jean claude
vercey qui s'est plongé dans les tuyaux
du web la fin de la neutralité du net
menace l'europe
le commissaire européen andrus ansip là
sur la neutralité du net continuera
d'exister dans l'union européenne
le principe de neutralité garantit un
traitement identique de tous les flux de
données sur internet
chaque internaute doit pouvoir visionner
une série télé ou s'adonner à un jeu
vidéo sur les sites de son choix depuis
le 25 novembre 2015 consommateur est
protégé par un règlement européen qui
précise les droits de l'internaute en
termes de vitesse et de qualité des
services
il interdit également aux fournisseurs
d'accès de discriminer l'utilisateur sur
la base de l'origine ou de la
destination des données et dans la
pratique un rapport du bureau européen
des régulateurs de communication
électronique rassemble les données de 30
régulateurs nationaux largement positif
ce rapport ne pointe que quelques
lacunes notamment en matière de
transparence des contrats des opérateurs
plus critique
les défenseurs du net relais des
comportements discriminatoires
le premier et l'exclusion de contenus un
fournisseur d'accès néerlandais a tenté
d'exclure de son réseau des applications
en concurrence avec les propres services
de téléphonie notamment skype autre
critique le chantage à la 4g
certains opérateurs prétendent pouvoir
garantir l'accès aux sites que via le
réseau le plus rapide est tant pis pour
ceux qui ne disposent pas du téléphone
ou du réseau adéquat le troisième sujet
de discorde et le zéro rétine cette
pratique consiste à offrir gratuitement
certains contenus sur base illimité
comme youtube ou facebook en les
excluant ainsi du volume accordé dans le
forfait
ce service respectent la réglementation
européenne mais à la seule condition que
les autres services ne soient pas
ralenti
enfin le quatrième danger celui de la
boîte dite prioritaire qui favoriserait
certes un contenu par une vitesse
d'acheminement plus rapide ce qui est
bien sûr interdit alors la neutralité du
net est elle vraiment assuré en europe
globalement la réponse est oui
voilà merci merci à vous d'avoir accepté
débattre c'est fini et si vous voulez
bien longtemps de voir et revoir cette
émission ça se casse sur les tuyaux
neutre du web
la semaine prochaine vous avez rendez
vous avec mon collègue ahmed tazir
depuis bruxelles très bonne semaine à
tous ciao ciao
[Musique]
à